because of all the energy the adrenaline
going on from the from the room you
cross that speech thank you so much oh
my gosh I'm so happy so happy and
thankful to the Center for having me
listen I know you can't get out for a
lot of things right now but you had to
show up for this one huh I had to show
up for the LGBT Center period what did
it mean to be up there and to receive
that honor and also what a beautiful uh
intro from Karama I gotta give him a
shout out oh my gosh it was first of all
caramo's speech was amazing the
introduction really touched me because I
grew up with Karama watching him and the
impact that he made on the community of
being on a show like real world
especially as a black man you know
owning his sexuality that really
impacted me I it's like every time I saw
him I would always bring it up because
it was such a big moment in my life
um and then I mean to be here tonight
it's just an honor to be seen um in this
way it's I don't even know if there's
really words I can put to it but I'm
just so grateful I haven't seen you
since you gave birth to baby Leo I know
I mean you must be missing them right
now I am I'm like I'm like yes thinking
about my little boy oh my gosh I love
him too much what has been your favorite
part so far of motherhood man my
favorite part you know I think it's our
mornings that's our mornings are alone
time together you know what I'm saying I
really love that moment I just get to
look out and get to look at my move we
do a little singing song and talking
he's laughing he's smiling and he's a
little sleepy so I don't have to hit him
cries you know it's just a little bit
everything so you singing to the baby
then I'll sing to the baby
have like a song that I wrote from this
sometimes I'm just like we doing this
we're doing that you know and I do a
little Rap Attack I get into it because
your life is a musical it's true it's
true
um what has been your favorite part of
seeing Darius as a father oh my gosh
probably just I mean I guess I don't
know what I would have expected but I
think he's just so attentive I guess
that's what you want our fathers to be
but it's even more than I expected it um
I just really am grateful to have such
an amazing partner to do this with but I
think that is obviously why we had the
kid together I saw Wade before that he
had the dedication of the patience and
what's the word I'm looking for like um
discipline to be an amazing dad and
that's why I wanted you know to have my
baby with them I'm so happy for you and
not for nothing you are still booked and
busy I mean you're dropping singles on
us mommy is working still and I got
something coming for y'all too Leo might
be a little actor as well we'll have to
see what's going on just stay posted for
the whole family it is a Visual Album oh
yes okay we got the big boss uh album
and movie honey get into it those of you
that are Amazon unlimited you probably
already seen it but don't even worry
it's going to be available for everybody
but get it to the big boss album waiting
single is out you won't be waiting too
much longer okay she's like you know
what I have a baby to take care of but
here's some music for the summer exactly
I want my son to have everything so I
got to stay booked and busy sounds like
Leo's working too okay so we got the bug
already I want everybody to work don't
come around me for too long if we get
close enough honey you're getting a job
okay she's a Jackson
she's like let's get the whole thing
because Darren's last name Miss Jackson
so you really let's go I love her well
I'm so happy for you congratulations
foreign